well if you think about it so many like
modern inventions and everything are
based on nature itself because Nature
has figured out how to do this yeah man
yeah so they try and make like this
smart machines like engineering uh
systems where they're based on like uh
real life structures because yeah like
uh like where they try and make uh these
like kind of RC planes that are based
more off like Wing structure like birds
yeah yeah exactly yeah obviously over
Evolution they've evolved a way that
works best yeah because because one day
some dude looked up to this guy saw a
bird flying and went I wouldn't do that
you know it's like how do you like
that's how it started yeah make makes
you wonder like how would you how would
you would planes be any different today
if Birds just didn't exist right so we
just don't have that framework if there
just wasn't an animal yeah it's the way
that like a plane works is very
different well I guess
well they have wings right well yeah I
mean it's
I I guess what part of engineering you
care about I mean because it's like we
just stuck a [__] explosion on there
because we couldn't figure out how to do
it in a way yeah it works the way that
they do it so we had we had a strap
[__] jet fuel that it burns you know
what I mean
but like the Wright brothers didn't have
that right they they steam I think now
is this steam oh no diesel now it's
diesel sorry of course it was pretty in
diesel engine yeah Kai look it up yeah
it's probably a diesel engine right
we're getting to the point of trash days
where we're just kind of like spewing
[__] over the bed because it was
like it was like they had the a compact
and lightweight enough system that could
that made it so you could power that
right and all you need to do is make an
aerofoil which is basically just
something that just catches the most
drag yeah
um and then you just [__] power
forward
all right all right yeah you know small
explosions all the way yeah Humanity
since the beginning boom that's that's
all that's all we love everything they
saw an explosion they saw momentum and
they went what if we just attached that
to something like that's how you that's
how you want to make a lightweight
system now it is getting closer and
closer in a sense to either either the
the amount of power we can generate or
the size of electricity needs to improve
a lot or you kind of get it closer to I
suppose you can get it's like a bird
wing and you can maybe get it more
perfect in the sense yeah but it depends
what you want to do because Birds can't
like uh Alberts a lot of the temperature
flap in place right like if you want a
drone you stop birds don't do that I
mean besides hummingbirds do yeah right
but then how do you how do you like
generate that yeah certain dragonflies
and stuff yeah dragonflies are the best
flyers in like nature holy [__] like I
sometimes I see a dragonfly fly maneuver
and it's insane yeah yeah
you just reminded me like I mean they
made mid-flight yeah I'm like that's
hippie like it literally now that I
think about I remember as a kid thinking
like dragonfly flights patterns look
like they're pre-programmed yeah
yeah it literally like [__] that's
incredible yeah I guess yeah depending
on what kind of plane you'd want to make
but what it would need to do you'd pick
the aerofoil right on the face I guess
you could there's nothing saying you
couldn't make a dragonfly-esque system I
think you just need it all to be
balanced and you'd need a way to power
that much force yeah
also that'd be a lot of G's I think if
you're whipping around that fast yeah
yeah don't don't dragonflies go through
like the the most IG force or something
animals I think I remember seeing
something like that going from static to
boom yeah yeah that's a lot that's a lot
yeah no we're not good at that well
obviously we've got [__] legs and
we're heavy dragonflies are [__]
light of [__] yeah but also often a lot
of times like birds and like like um a
lot of the times their skulls kind of
evolve to do certain things like um
woodpeckers they just wrap their tongue
around their brain to absorb it you know
that are you serious your tongue wraps
around their brain
that's right I'm trying to Google this
[__] that's crazy
if you like got into a car crash you're
just like hold on I'm Gonna Save myself
from getting an aneurysm that legit yeah
look at this look at the diagram the the
tongue wraps around the brain oh that's
epic [__] like give some kind of cushion
to their brain
nature just follows it up hentai like
concept you know what I mean that's what
is that okay explain that concept to me
let's break it down
[Music]
tell me that or something tell me the
plot what's the plot
yeah you could write something yeah so
that's something new man
hey I can't come up with that [__]
[Laughter]
we [__] up Humanity we've trained AI
to like come up with [__] with brain
with brain wrap tonguing brain wrapped
oh my God yeah maybe she's thinking of
all different types of planes now it
makes me want to know how how did how
did the invention of like the helicopter
how did that get like did that's
actually a [__] [__] sick history
uh because the guy who made it is a
[__] psychopath he just was like you
have to be like I look at the helicopter
he was like determined to die like if
you look at the history of like the
models of how I made it I swear one of
the dudes he was trying to make it was
like actually insane yeah like it
crashed so many times right but he just
kept me trying to make more because he
was like dead set on it there's also
like a genius at invention really yeah
yeah I mean I I mean I I don't I I fully
believe that because I look at a
helicopter and you're just like that
shouldn't fly I like I don't know modern
technology we're living in a simulation
I always thought helicopters were way
cooler than planes I was a helicopter
gang all the way wait how was team
helicopter
do not have this like you just you just
like when I saw like a battle helicopter
I think that's just purely based on the
fact that like you don't see you don't
see helicopters as often as planes yeah
sure and all the helicopters you see are
kind of lame they're all kind of like
you know normal ones but they're
actually the ones with guns like whoa
something in your boy brain you're like
oh that's cool
I think it looked lame I I think it's
also just the
like the idea of the helicopter let's
let's spin this thing so [__] kind of
fast
as a kid I'm just like yo I'll just fly
but staying yeah just just stay in the
air planes you're just like it's got a
[__] engine to like make you go
I don't [__] care about that let's
try spinning some [__] blades to get
you up in the air that's metal as [__]
man yeah you know that's badass yeah
which makes all the more funny when have
you seen those videos where you see like
the helicopter like taking off but like
the frame rate of the camera shutter
speed yeah so it just looks like it's
stains
someone just turned grounded yeah it
just looks like it's suspended in the
air and just like going up
the first person to discover that is a
genius it's like a [__] Looney Tunes
walk you through the camera and they're
like what the [__] well I mean uh I mean
it happens a lot natural like so when
we're filming now right like obviously
uh a lot of light flickers yeah you know
you're in Japan I don't know which side
you're on it's either flickering 50
times a second or or 60. yeah right
obviously it's not actually like fully
going on off but it's you know and
sometimes on camera you set the hurts
um if you set the shutter speed to the
wrong thing or yeah you have it on maybe
a different anti-flicker mode yeah
you'll see it like the waves yeah
appearing on them so sometimes you can
even actually seeing like flickering
slides yeah no no you see it pretty
[__] bad I've got a lot of video
footage where it's happened and you're
like God damn it's [__] unusable it's
[__] flickering yeah well there's a
there's a lot of that you know the human
sensors can't take in there's so many
like spectrums of light and everything
like that I imagine you could see
[__] infrared and that's [__] sick
like I love the um you know the mantis
shrimp yeah I [__] love that that
thing's cool that's one of my favorite
things that's one of my favorite animals
of all time yeah that's the stories of
it busting glass because it's just it
like it's like boils the air yeah front
of it yeah
it literally creates almost like a
nuclear explosion yeah from how fast it
moves in terms of in terms of like the
heat and pressure it creates it's just
like boom it's like a sonic boom
basically yeah it's Sonic moves yeah
it's kind of crazy that like fish could
evolve to that I wish we [__] evolved
to that yeah
I'm just like yeah I look at the mantis
shrimp and I'm just like [__] we go
wrong yeah wait wait where the [__] did
we go wrong you know because like
her one shrimp the one shrimp in history
saw a clam and thought the only the most
optimal way to get inside this clam is
punching the [__] out of it I'm like
that's this is the crazy on paper if I
asked you can't yeah do you want
intelligence or do you want an arm that
can [__] boil air you'd be like I I
would like the arm that boils yeah I
would like to see every color please can
you tell me there's more colors I can't
see and then then these [__] little
shrimp but they're just on the [__]
ocean floor yeah and then we're the ones
who evolved well isn't that [__] dumb
because when I'm playing I feel about
this when I'm playing d d I'm like I'm
like man obviously I'm gonna smack into
like Wizardry or like Charisma I never
put anything in intelligence because
they always get it no they always get it
wrong in video games intelligence should
be way more op in video games yeah this
is humanity is what happens when you try
to balance out all the skill points
we just average on everything compared
to the Animal Kingdom we put all of our
stats into intelligence yeah we can't
even appreciate that yeah we're not
intelligent enough to appreciate that
yeah we're like all the points in
intelligence and the ability to throw
things that's pretty much everything we
did yeah yeah I'll be pretty good at
running
well I mean compared to like a cheetah
well that's the thing a lot of animals
use composable thumbs that's pretty
[__] op yeah a lot of animals can't
run like marathons
we can run for pretty long I mean I
can't I I didn't get that some of us can
some of us are pretty [__] beautiful
I'll let them do it yeah I'm I'm I
straight into the agile Industries